let me walk you through what we're gonna
do with this I just want you to see this
is what happens when I said if you want
more accuracy than this right as you
traverse across the field you just take
more measurements okay so more
measurements gives you more many buds
gives you more corners on your polygon
which means for more detail in theory
okay so you can see these people have
walked up they've taken one to the left
there pick another one to the right and
then the second one to the left so that
gives some three done this off on this
side but before we actually go ahead and
work out some stuff on this how would we
write the numbers for this diagram I'll
give you a clue it starts with zero okay
so the easiest one is 14 that's fair
enough because it's like look I walked
up that far and then I measured through
the left so that's where my 20 go now
then they keep on moving up but when I
draw this diagram when I write this down
here not my numbers are supposed to be
she living it now baby when you are
doing your diagram up there your numbers
out there you didn't do the cumulative
if you want them in this form that's the
way they're supposed to be so we make
sure we understand this progress up the
page I think so therefore the next
number should be 14 plus 8 which is 22
and then after that distance what do we
do we've measured this way okay
and then the pattern continues if you
put another 8 on there you're gonna get
30 after which they measured to the left
28
start it again I had which number oh you
mean like these numbers okay the answer
is like a Judy's down this key way
accumulate the answer is no because each
time I'm measuring these these are
completely disconnected distances like
there literally are not connected to
each other whereas these you can see I'm
trying to progress all the way along the
diagonal that make sense
what's my last time I go and your
diagram starting to dummies rather not
finished okay so obviously you could go
and reverse if I gave you these numbers
you generate this okay now let me just
say two more things are looking to
calculate this frame you guys can do
that when you get through the exercise
the first thing is how many different
shapes are in this composite figure I
count five right I count one triangle
here two three four and then you've got
this last shape which is not a triangle
it's a trapezium now the first thing I
wanna point out is like this numbering
is not something I just do just because
it looks nice this is how I'm going to
write out my tights I I'm going to say
something like area one equal right and
I like just cuz it's easy I will
actually do this one it's gonna be 1/2
times base times height and then I'm
gonna go ahead and calculate but doing
this makes sure that I miss any right
it's a look I put five numbers on my
diagram there better be five areas here
and I'm gonna add it all up the last
thing is I just want to remind you it's
a trapezium how do I work out the area
of retro PDM again okay so our formula
is 1/2 times the perpendicular height
now have a look
where's the perpendicular height on this
trapezium a lady
yeah it's this whole distance here which
is 16
yeah so I know that it's all substituted
in a minute what do I multiply them by
after that
okay now how do I know which ones are
these numbers and it's the parallel
edges in a trapezium there's only one
pair appease you
yeah so when I actually evaluate this
it's going to be half of a Utah PA plus
8 16 times 120 plus 28 and then you can
go ahead and work out what that is okay
and once you've got your four triangles
you want trapezium add it all together
so constructed carefully very how to
interpret this has that when you're
adding up all the pieces just none of
them make it easy for yourself so you
don't miss any and then I think that's
all I need to say and I think it's a
composite area so it's from 5d I don't
know what number it is but it doesn't
matter you've got this big parallelogram
on the outside there air is the
indicator but I don't let's make my
diagram normal and out of the
parallelogram they're kind of rhombus
now I know it's a rhombus how do I know
it's a woman's all all the sides are
equal
okay so you got all those my dear don't
pack up yet I just want you to focus
because I know lots of your water birds
the answers questions now because they
don't want to make the diagram too crazy
they've actually put over here on the
side
two extra bits of information now give
you two extra lengths these are the
lengths they give you okay from memory I
think man three and fine okay so
therefore how am I going to put this all
together okay well just like normally I
want to work out my big area it's a
parallelogram and I've got into place
and its height what's the area of a
parallelogram it's just the product of
those two seven times ten right then I
have to subtract the rhombus that's been
sliced out of the corner right but again
you need to know what how do I work out
the area
rhombus huh um the the formula says x y
where x and y are the diagonals right
three fun okay so try yourself a good
diagram and they might give you
measurements that aren't drawn to the
diagram so draw them okay